à l'intérieur on va dire que tu cela
comme ça on fera le pape ou plouffe avec
quimby avec michèle laroque avec vent
avec tout le monde allait michèle
laroque et maroc
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
michèle laroque qui met en scène enfin
il faut aller voir son spectacle à mon
cher moi on va en parler dans un instant
mais on était sûr keen'v keen'v avec son
nouvel album saltimbanques et qui devait
vous avez participé à l'émission splash
le grand plongeon
on vous avait elle vous a rappelé pour
le faire mais non j'avais baissé parce
qu'il allait on s'est croisés et ça fait
une heure je cherche dans quelle
émission n'en est d'ailleurs mise à
faire d'excusés il avait aussi danse
avec les stars est plus un grand
chanteur qui cartonne oui ça je sais oui
mais je le savais qu'il y avait une
émission en plus red bull arrive à la
piscine c'est tout mettez moi c'est
demain par de reconnaître tout de suite
se laisser décourager par ce plan je
sais qu'on fait l'émission ici
rappelez-vous dans la semaine et vous
voyez ça y'a pas de soucis alors où ce
plh le grand plongeon 10